[Music]
welcome back everybody we finish off in
Los Angeles where Harvey Weinstein
continues to face sexual assault
allegations in court this time from the
first partner of a government official
Jennifer siebel Newsom the wife of
California governor Gavin Newsom told
the jury on Monday that she was raped by
Weinstein in 2005. she is one of five
women testifying against the disgraced
Hollywood Mogul as he faces 11 sexual
assault charges and a possible life
sentence Newsom said her assault took
place in a Beverly Hills Hotel room
describing the event as a quote my worst
nightmare at the time Newsome said she
was a quote working actress and believed
that Weinstein would help her career she
said Weinstein would eventually force
himself onto her and she tried to resist
on cross-examination Weinstein's
attorney questioned a donation to Newsom
suggesting it was from his own client
following the alleged assault Newsom
replied by saying quote it's complex her
cross-examination continued on Tuesday
let's turn to my co-host Terry Austin
Terry Harvey Weinstein has been accused
of sexual assault by dozens of women and
he was previously convicted of sexual
assault out here in New York can you
tell us a little bit more about who
these women are what their claims are
you know what Jesse at this point over
80 women have accused Harvey Weinstein
of sexual assault and where there's fire
there's smoke and where there's smoke
there's fire you can usually say that
these women they're all in the film
industry and they were approached by
Weinstein under the guise that he could
help them with their careers many of the
women allege that he was not at all
interested in helping them with their
careers instead he assaulted them and he
forced them to perform sexual acts
Jennifer Newsom she was the fourth of
the five accusers to testify in the
California case she broke down into
tears shortly after taking the witness
stamp the prosecutor simply asked her to
identify Weinstein Newsom did identify
him but she began crying and she said
that he was quote staring at her it just
demonstrates Jesse how difficult it is
to to testify about sexual assault
Newsome is a Stanford University
graduate she's produced oscar-winning
films she's even campaigned along her
husband you know Gavin Newson and she's
accustomed to speaking in public and yet
her direct examination she admitted that
she was nervous and she needed to take a
deep breath the cross-examination is
going to be even more difficult because
she's going to have to explain why she
didn't report that rape and she's going
to have to explain that donation to her
husband's campaign so yeah and I want to
bring you in on this Brian because how
do you think her testimony compares to
the other uh survivors that have
testified as well so I think her
testimony is comparable to the other
survivors in the sense that it shows a
similar act by a similar man but I think
it's almost defense proof in the sense
of those arguments of buyer's remorse
she's the governor's wife she's moved on
to a much better life credibility she
she's again the governor's wife and and
Terry's already kind of listed her
credentials out there she's probably one
of the more credible people in that
courtroom testifying and so these
arguments that defense attorneys will
often lob at these alleged victims to
try to pull them apart she's almost
defense proof in the sense of who she is
and of course you look at the county
that they're in they very much love her
husband and probably love her as well
it's going to be tough for the defense
to pull her apart yeah
deja vu all over again Brian Terry thank
you so much great reporting and Analysis
as always everyone out there thanks for
joining us here on Long crime daily
we'll see you next time
Justice
[Music]